>>> THIS WEEK ACROSS THE GLOBE
WE PAUSE TO REMEMBER THE MOST
EXTENSIVELY DOCUMENTED CRIME IN
THE HISTORY OF THE WORLD.
INTERNATIONAL HOLOCAUST
REMEMBRANCE DAY COMMEMORATES THE
6 MILLION JEWISH VICTIMS AND
MILLIONS OF OTHERS PERSECUTED
AND MURDERED BY THE NAZIS DURING
WORLD WAR II.
FOR THE RECORD, IT IS PROFOUNDLY
DISRESPECTFUL TO THE MEMORIES OF
SURVIVORS AND THE SUFFERING OF
THOSE WHO WERE KILLED TO EQUATE
THE HOLOCAUST TO ANYTHING.
BUT THAT DOES NOT STOP MOSTLY
REPUBLICAN LAWMAKERS AND PUBLIC
FIGURES FROM TRYING TO COMPARE
WHAT IS GOING ON RIGHT NOW TO
THIS HORRIBLE TIME IN HUMAN
HISTORY.
LAST WEEKEND ROBERT F. KENNEDY
JR. SUGGESTED ANNE FRANK, THE
FAMOUS TEENAGER WHO HID FROM THE
NAZIS IN AN ATTIC IN THE
NETHERLANDS BEFORE BEING CAUGHT
AND SENT TO DIE IN A
CONCENTRATION CAMP, WAS BETTER
OFF UNDER HITLER THAN AMERICANS
WHO ARE CURRENTLY SUBJECT TO
VACCINE MANDATES.
>> EVEN IN HITLER'S GERMANY YOU
COULD -- YOU COULD CROSS THE
ALPS INTO SWITZERLAND.
YOU CAN HIDE IN AN ATTIC LIKE
ANNE FRANK DID.
I VISITED IN 1962 EAST GERMANY
WITH MY FATHER AND MET PEOPLE
WHO HAD CLIMBED THE WALL AND
ESCAPED.
SO IT WAS POSSIBLE.
MANY DIED TRYING BUT IT WAS
POSSIBLE.
TODAY THE MECHANISMS ARE BEING
PUT IN PLACE THAT WILL MAKE IT
SO NONE OF US CAN RUN AND NONE
OF US CAN HIDE.
>> KENNEDY LATER APOLOGIZED.
HIS OWN WIFE CONDEMNED HIS
COMMENTS.
AND JUST TWO WEEKS AGO A
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN FROM
OHIO, WARREN DAVIDSON, TWEETED
AN IMAGE OF A NAZI DOCUMENT AND
WROTE THE FOLLOWING.
"THIS HAS BEEN DONE BEFORE.
#DO NOT COMPLY.
LET'S RECALL THAT THE NAZIS
DEHUMANIZED JEWISH PEOPLE BEFORE
SEGREGATING THEM, SEGREGATED
THEM BEFORE IMPRISONING THEM,
IMPRISONED THEM BEFORE ENSLAVING
THEM, AND ENSLAVED THEM BEFORE
MASSACRING THEM."
SO WHAT KIND OF EGREGIOUS ACT
DROVE DAVIDSON TO REACT THIS
WAY?
IT WAS THE MAYOR OF WASHINGTON,
D.C. REQUIRING ADULTS TO HAVE
PROOF OF OF A COVID VACCINATION,
A PHOTO I.D., AND WEAR A MASK
WHILE INDOORS IN PUBLIC.
DAVIDSON LATER APOLOGIZED.
AND THEN THERE'S COLORADO
CONGRESSWOMAN LAUREN BOEBERT.
BACK IN JULY SHE REFERRED TO
DOOR-TO-DOOR VACCINE AWARENESS
ADVOCATES SUPPORTED BY THE CDC
AS NEEDLE NAZIS.
AND OF COURSE DON'T FORGET
GEORGIA REPUBLICAN CONGRESSWOMAN
MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE, SHE WENT
TO THE NATIONAL HOLOCAUST MUSEUM
IN WASHINGTON AND APOLOGIZED FOR
USING HOLOCAUST COMPARISONS TO
CRITICIZE FACE MASK MANDATES ON
THE HOUSE FLOOR.
>> THE HOLOCAUST IS -- THERE'S
NOTHING COMPARABLE TO IT.
IT'S -- IT'S -- IT HAPPENED AND,
YOU KNOW, OVER 6 MILLION JEWISH
PEOPLE WERE MURDERED.
AND THERE ARE WORDS THAT I HAVE
SAID AND REMARKS THAT I HAVE
MADE THAT I KNOW ARE OFFENSIVE.
AND FOR THAT I WANT TO
APOLOGIZE.
>> NOTHING TO COMPARE TO IT.
I AGREE.
BUT THEN WEEKS LATER GREENE WAS
BACK AT IT, AS YOU'LL RECALL,
ATTACKING EFFORTS BY THE WHITE
HOUSE TO ENCOURAGE AMERICANS TO
GET VACCINATED BY CALLING THOSE
LEADING THE EFFORTS "BROWN
SHIRTS."
THAT IS A REFERENCE TO THE
PARAMILITARY ORGANIZATION THAT
HELPED HITLER AND THE NAZI PARTY
RISE TO POWER.
THEY WERE ALSO KNOWN AS BROWN
SHIRTS.
THESE ARE JUST A FEW EXAMPLES.
IN FACT, WE DID A CURSORY LOOK
AND FOUND AT LEAST 32 EXAMPLES
FROM LAWMAKERS USING HOLOCAUST
COMPARISONS JUST IN THE LAST TWO
YEARS SINCE THE BEGINNING OF THE
PANDEMIC.
THE HOLOCAUST SHOULD NOT BE USED
TO MAKE POLITICAL POINTS.
THE SYSTEMATIC TARGETING AND
GENOCIDE OF JEWISH PEOPLE IS NOT
IN THE SAME UNIVERSE WHATSOEVER
AS PUBLIC HEALTH MEASURES
INTENDED TO KEEP PEOPLE SAFE
DURING A PANDEMIC.
THE DEATHS OF 6 MILLION JEWS
SHOULD NOT BE A PUNCHLINE OR A
WAY TO RALLY SUPPORTERS.
IF THEY WANT TO BRING UP THE
HOLOCAUST, MAYBE IT SHOULD BE
THE FIGHT TO KEEP BOOKS ABOUT IT
IT IN SCHOOL CURRICULUMS.
LIKE THE BOOK "MAUS," A PULITZER
PRIZE-WINNING GRAPHIC NOVEL
ABOUT THE EXPERIENCES OF
HOLOCAUST SURVIVORS AND THEIR
CHILDREN.
JUST THIS WEEK THE MICKMAN
COUNTY, TENNESSEE BOARD OF
EDUCATION VOTED UNANIMOUSLY TO
BAN THE BOOK FROM AN
EIGHTH-GRADE CURRICULUM,
ALLEGEDLY OVER CONCERNS OF
LANGUAGE AND THE SMALL DRAWING
OF A NUDE WOMAN.
MAYBE OUR TIME IS BETTER SPENT